okay um
i could just stare and chat in
fascination or
i could play chess or i could try and do
both
um i feel like it's been
it's been a while since i've played some
serious games
happy two months chess cargo
i assume the t is silent unless it's
chess car got
or is it misspelled chess car god
thanks for subbing
um and thanks everyone for the bits too
shout out to europe
trying to be friendly to the europeans
okay hey it's london let's play c5 and
knight c6
there's a cool line actually maybe we
can
we can transpose into something knight
d2 yeah this is what i play as white
and i'm gonna go into this kind of sharp
variation
i was showing andrea botes this other
day
um from the white side
and there's a cool move here e4
to frozen and call it frozen
wait what oh frozen spelled with an s
instead of a z
um i should do a parody and call it the
frozen rosen
okay now i think it's time to to take
the pawn
a knight b3 runs into this
it's a weird position my queen's a bit
awkward but
i am up upon i have to take this way
i think the queen can return to c3
these positions usually the bishop wants
to be on e5
to hit the queen but okay this also
looks possible
uh probably time to castle
knight c6 coming bishop has to find a
square
probably like bishop c5 thanks for
subbing pratsen
and chess cargo oh chas cargo the t is
silent
just like my my starbucks tea is not
making
any noise right now um i play bishop c5
allowing no rook b3 oh rook b3 is kind
of annoying
i could play queen c5 queen c5
we might end up trading oh no
oh no i think i'm allowing
oh no ah my queen
i could lose a bishop too i have
this move oh this is really bad
what do i do here i could cry
oh yeah maybe later i'll be doing viewer
challenges
if i take yeah maybe i'll take in bishop
a6
there goes my queen the hope is here and
then here and i'll win some material
that's not looking good though oh thanks
for the sub
so okay i think
no i should leave the rook hanging let's
play this move
because the rook is kind of trapped now
i'm trying to get comp
like the the bishops the knights
it kind of makes up for not having a
queen right
let's put a rook in a happier place
maybe listen this eventually
wait free rook is it a miracle
it's a miracle oh but the white wants to
meet me
so i could take with check
yeah i can't play i'll start by taking
with check and then i'll play g6
yeah f6 would run into this and i'd lose
stuff
i'm probably still losing stuff what's
this position
should we trade
there's h5
h5 is a weird move the point
is that i'm chasing the queen away from
covering e6
so after queen f3 i take and then
actually unleash the rook
i might be winning the night here
this is such a weird game to start the
stream
i think i'm okay
i'm i'm actually covering like most of
the squares
the queen could move to
um let's defend
there's a cool move bishop f1 maybe
maybe h let's take a thing
okay i'll double up rooks are safe here
i have a lot of material for the queen
now
okay so i want to do this and then rook
f1 mate i'm threatening made in three
let's go it's force mate now
let's go wow what a weird game
i just lost the queen and now i'm mating
okay
that's why you never give up
uh i don't even know what to make of
that game
i really botched the the early middle
game
whoa it's gme short seller thanks for
the
the ten dollars yeah i'm not sure if
that was a very
holy game uh
it was kind of a theoretical like trendy
line um
i'll be posting a video to youtube in a
few days
where i was showing andrea botezus from
the white side
and showing the move e4 here and then
there's some cool traps like if takes
you
you play knight c4 and you trap the
queen
but 95 also a logical move
and i probably have to study this more
from the black side because it just gets
really sharp
so queen c5 bus move best move
bus move hello ah bishop a6
hey it's yorkshire hello welcome back
wait that's not icelandic noob oh that's
icelandic noob perfect timing for you
nice
who was that that was joe says hello
yeah hello
hello from st louis and hoffman haha
thanks for subbing y'all can welcome
back
so i guess i i made a mistake with one
of the most natural moves
but bishop basics is also very logical
because i just develop with tempo
and if rookie won ah then i have rook c8
so knight e takes c6
i can take on f1 well it gets really
complicated
takes takes like white gets a lot of
compensation my king is uncastled
it's tricky to evaluate even stockfish
doesn't know how to evaluate this
zero zero it sometimes means drawn but
also sometimes means
that the engine is just confused
okay so that was a small lesson so i
blundered with castling
and then it was already difficult and
then i yeah rook b5 just crushes me
but yeah i was able to make use of the
bishop hair the knight the rook and i
think white got a bit too relaxed
so let's move on that was the first game
i think the goal
the goal is to play good moves
and gain rating and maybe hit 2600
just have to take it one game at a time
okay let's play
d4 thanks uh yeah thanks for so many
people subbing and cheering bits
um the cherny went zero out of four
that's how you learn especially if
you're
if you're a newer player i think italian
game
it's very playable um
italian can sometimes be tricky to play
in the middle game because
it requires more maneuvering it's more
closed position
so i might recommend like scotch or
ponziani something a bit more open
where the ideas are a bit more natural
so g6 what do i play against this move
i should know what to play i mean i
could go into benoni
i think i'll play just a normal london
setup like c3
i'll play a bit more positionally i also
spend way too much time
on move move forward there
um so we're playing a time gambit queen
here i have knight p3
the what oh
the jobava london at first i thought
that said
if i ever play the jab over the london
like the jab rather than the london um
only against specific setups from black
like against king's indian or grunfeld
then it's more likely but not
not quite in this game
so i did lose some time moving the
bishop here and here
um but now that the pawn is here i have
good control over e5
hello hello
juler thanks for subbing
and bearded will welcome back gifting to
snoozing 68.
yeah that's a very typical idea i think
i think i'll play bishop g5
and if black wants to trade off
knight for bishop they have to like kind
of weaken the
king side a bit
there's also a weird idea to me g5 with
knight e1
so after it takes i take the knight
somehow i'm up on time it's moving very
slow early on
okay let's play this move i'm okay with
this trade bishop's not doing too much
and it's likely e5 will happen at some
point
but maybe not soon because the bishop
has some x-ray vision
hey it's irene what's up irene
good job to irene irene played in the
european
online chess club cup championships
or something it was like the eccc or
something like that
irene won all her games today
i was thinking about streaming it but
then i got busy
ah i could move i've c4 here
c4 is very typical when whenever black
plays f6
because i want to open this diagonal
[Music]
wow so i can
if i take first on e5
the issue for black is when i take
there's no queen takes because bishop c4
okay so i'm up a pawn
might as well go for a
rook train the queen's a bit awkward
here
queen wants to be here but maybe not
because knight c4
also there's issues with the back rank
yeah i think this is really pleasant for
white despite black having the bishop
hair
not too useful here
hello eric hello
play queen b3 i just want to optimize
all the pieces
and make them better than box pieces
so there's g6 check
how to do this
oh there's a cool idea starting with
this and then after this i
take if rook takes and i play this and
let's do this anyway
it's going to come down to time probably
queen f7 is a move
maybe not let's take and play this
queenie one i have knight f1
my pawn should be stronger than black's
d-pawn
also i'm winning the rook i think or
just queening
oh i'm not queening bishop f6
let's bring the knight back
so i want to have to do this
here let's win a pawn
okay it's winning
i can dance around with the knight
let's go okay that was an interesting
game
it took patience um there's some
uh some weirdness in the middle game i
mean black went for a very kind of
direct way of playing with f
knight h5 f6 uh i think the key move of
the game
that kind of led to the nice nice
position with c4
just to pressure d5 and black wasn't
prepared
i wasn't actually prepared for the
center to open up
okay thank you cj
[Music]
subbing for three months
also welcome everyone yeah it's hard to
look at chat
while i play some of these games because
um i'm playing good players i'm trying
to play accurately
irene asking can i sub you forever
uh
well you you could sum it in advance
actually i don't know how far in advance
there's been people subbing for
i think maximum one year in advance
it doesn't happen too often but that's
still
a ways off from forever i guess
yeah if you sub to me for like
what's the average lifespan 70 years 780
years
um how much would that cost
there should be like a bulk discount or
an eventual senior discount
also hello stagran
so we're going into um a non-staffer
gambit this is
this is just another line in the petrov
when white plays d4
it's a bit more positional it's a bit
weird too because the knight is
on d6
so recently i've i've been playing a
setup with g6 bishop g7
the bishop is nicely placed i'm
realizing that could be an issue though
i'm just gonna have to deal with it i
mean rookie one i may have already
misplayed this
because knight g5 okay there's no
bishops e4
so knight g5 like castle
after takes takes i would hit the queen
okay this looks reasonable
also thank you dan h play queen f6 here
i could connect four with my minor
pieces on the sixth rank
if we trade queens ooh
[Music]
okay let's just put the pieces on happy
central squares
two center files are open oh white also
connected four
so we could we could have a connect four
face off
g5 is a good move
so if we trade
and then we trade some more
i'm thinking takes and then bishop it's
taking bishop g4
hitting the rook good evening eric
how are you doing hey good evening i
assume you're
in europe for stalin matt
i am doing well up a little bit of time
[Music]
a position slightly unpleasant
also it's afternoon for me it's 12 48
p.m
in st louis thank you yan 42
and the c7 pawn is actually kind of weak
i might be just losing a pawn here
i do have this move maybe
i'm trying to get the bishop hair
so if i take i should take with pawn
it's ugly
i'm trying to make this work
okay i'm not scared of this or this
oh wait a minute am i winning a piece f5
it's interesting there's this move
but the point is yeah wait it's
complicated
i had to save the bishop the bishop
moved back i would win the night
now the night's a bit awkward oh my
i don't know what's going on here
just trying to hold my ground
what is this position
oh no i think i am losing a piece
or am i because takes i take with a rook
i'm losing up wait i might not be losing
a pawn because takes i take here
on f3 tacticos
and again if this i have this or this
discover checks
ooh um
okay so somehow i'm up material now
rook d7 i maybe just defend
down a little bit of time but position
should be much easier to play
i can just play on the light squares
i'll put everything on light squares
a king should be coming this way
here we go okay
that was a weird game i was probably
much worse there at some point
and then
i didn't lose material i really thought
i was gonna lose material
around here because there is so much
pressure from all different sorts of
directions
as pawn was kind of weak
uh engine says white's better
so knight g7 best move best move
ah king f1 is actually pretty
instructive
when the king's here it defends the rook
it threatens to
take here it just puts the king
somewhere so it it's not running into
discoveries
but white was yeah it was a bit too
quick to take the pawn
oh yeah we can we can have predictions
i'll probably be playing
the remainder of this tournament
have i played magnus yet yeah that's one
of the most recent videos
on youtube
ah so i'll admit
i don't if you asked me that
maybe seven eight years ago
[Music]
i was uh that was back when i was a
member of the
the team um this is referring to the the
university of illinois
at urbana-champaign chess club um
i'm pretty sure they still have a like a
crowd of players
but um i'd recommend checking their
facebook page
whoa hey it's gm houston beth
thanks so much for the raid i appreciate
that
for those just joining i'm playing the
elite super blitz arena also shout out
yeah shout out to nicholas fusionbeth
so there's a question about uh the
university of illinois chess club
and while i was playing for university
of illinois
i actually played houston beth in the
the final four
of college chess
and we had a we had a very hard fought
game
but he just he basically just crushed me
the game is somewhere online
okay so um let's play
someone was asking about job in london
earlier
i played the first three moves of jobava
london but this is more going into uh
a pierce oh i showed this to andrea
botez the other day
um we were looking at 97.
oh no my sub oh yesterday sub
thanks for subbing super misplays
the main idea is to play e5 eventually
it should be six maybe okay can i play
e5 here
how did you set up the bot to play
against the chat i am curious
oh you should ask you should ask
uh andrew chess or brian brian
because they're they actually they
programmed two different bots that
made it possible using the i think the
twitch
and the chass apis
okay i'm moving a little bit slowly here
still calculating e5
there's this crazy move too which
basically just trades pieces
is rook g1 i'm trying to stay flexible
each board at some point
it was tts quiet
i forgot to check the levels i just
raised it a little bit
okay so one plan is bishop h3
oh did i miss something i missed
something kind of
well now it's too late
huh
there's an interesting idea here
start with this move i missed 95 at the
right moment
oh i missed something else too or no i
didn't
there's there's a really cool tactical
idea which um
it might be hard to get but
now it's probably impossible i was
thinking knight b5 at the right moment
but i have to save my queen i could play
rook
rook g5 is insane
probably just not good
i'm moving way too slowly
interesting to take
okay playing some some solid chests now
bishop probably wants to go here pin the
knight
induce king b8 maybe this move coming
the pawn
[Music]
um
so e5 we trade
i could take
i think it's okay
idea takes e5 takes
it might not be okay but now it's too
late i just have to
open prey
yeah this is no good
[Music]
this is going to be unpleasant it's
equal material that i'm down upon
something made in two oh no my pawn
please take it i'm also threatening this
pawn too
oh it's mate oh no my queen
okay that's a cool mating idea
i really thought i was gonna get like
positionally ground down
[Music]
and flagged
because my time management was so bad
that came
oh no some people's channel points was
there a prediction there
oh there was but what was the prediction
that was nice um
i feel like there was probably some
missed opportunity
i should show there's um a really
typical
tactical motif whenever the queens are
aligned like this
it only works when the king's on b1 not
when the king's on c1
is to play this move knight d5
i think i i can get away with it in this
position
[Music]
and the point um is i hit the queen
so black doesn't have time to take the
knight and if takes here
i would take here first and then regain
the queen
but i'm not sure if it works because the
knight might get trapped
like rook here it gets weird though
because i have this move
white's worse after bishop h6 that's
crazy
or some other other engine moves
twitch urging me to share one quarter of
rosen
one quarter of rosen like 25 cents
one quarter oh well thank you killer
dolphin
or oh three months like a quarter of a
year
but also a third of a baby
i appreciate the resub
also hello to grandmaster gary
also congrats to grandmaster yari who
got his
fifth or sixth i am norm
on the road to i am
also pam how's it going good to see you
and thank you x broken gun
okay um did i miss anything
i was most winning here
so i missed knight b5 at the right
moment
why is it so strong
oh because eventually bishop h3 too many
opportunities to watch you stream
lately but you will always earn my
prime sub i haven't even played chess
lately but i still love your channel
i love you too thanks for being you well
thank you
dork 96 knight i appreciate that
subbing for seven months with prime
okay yeah there are some stopper tunes
that game should really make an effort
to
stay more focused so less than an hour
left
in the tournament um i've been gaining
some reading
playing pirate roman
staffer gambit time i've actually
noticed like
i've played a decent number of players
from ukraine lately
a lot of them will will enter this
position
[Music]
um so maybe it's like a
a more common opening rapper tour in
ukraine to
go into stafford which is nice
okay so we're playing the beginning
of the jonathan tronce magical line
of epicness opponents thinking
oh so this position uh queen d4 this is
my
my prep for carlson which never actually
transpired
against carlson but i can use it against
other people
so i induce white to castle and now with
the queen on d6 i'm going for this
typical
kind of fishing pole concept
it's not easy to figure out as white
bishop e3
i feel like i have had this move
i feel like i'm just supposed to
wait i posted this to youtube recently i
take and then take on h3
and then here here torture the king and
then eventually either this or this
um i'm pretty sure this is the best move
knight g4
but i think this was easier to
understand
and the problem for white is the king is
super naked if king f2
trying to run i would have
ah there's bishop f3 i'd have queen h4
there
so bishop f3 i have knight g4
it still takes work
start with this
i'll start with my g4 so i'm putting
this and
made in one
i know the engine gives like plus seven
after queen h3
for black oh don't be sad
oh well i guess it's on me to keep you
not sad
okay so now i can open h files still
threatening mate
g3 ideas if queen e2
natural move i play queen h1 king f2
and then at the very least work h2
and this should be yeah this is force
made i believe
or just winning a rookie queen
[Music]
so if king goes back it's made in a few
and then if here i win the rook and if
here i
check and then win the rook and mate
okay that was nice
i was um that was the same line right
let's find the video
so if you go to my my youtube channel
and you scroll down
so carlson's made a few appearances in
my thumbnail like this one
and then this one it was funny like i
i released this video and then a few
weeks later i play carlson
and he just turned down the stafford
so can maybe
show the key position
yeah so we had the same position from
this video this was
february 21st
and my opponent
oh yeah i also played i also played rook
h6 in this game
oh but the knight was on d2
so maybe it was a bit different
real quick i'll check with engine wait
made in three
i've made in three oh i missed made in
three
i guess i was confusing when the knights
on d2
so this is just made in queen g3 knight
g4
wait how did what's the line with knight
t2
oh it was completely different this game
we played into a line where i won the
b-pawn came back to e5 and then did
things on the queen side
so white wouldn't have time for knight
f3 here
yeah i made false assumptions in this
game i'm on my way home from vegas
oh again i missed made into instead of
taking the bishop right away
queen g3 and then pawn discovery
takes bishop checkmate
okay so sometimes this is a mistake i
rely
on things i think i've seen before
but i just got confused and then
it's not exactly the same thing but it
still worked out
let's move on 68th place
very nice 16 points
playing no pieces
soon to be no pieces okay let's take all
all of my opponent's pieces so plan for
this game
yeah this move order could be tricky oh
we're just transposing
oh we're getting the same line as i was
i played this uh the first game of the
tournament
with the black side so bishop here i
think i can
still play e4
i'm not entirely sure though i do this
against
e6 bishop e7 it looks to be the same
thing though
[Music]
so the point is rook b3 and the queen's
trapped
let's go eric now the one mistake i
remember making after takes takes
castling oh that's possible
wait i can take the queen or play this
move
ah but there's bishop g4
[Music]
so maybe i should take your first
i play rookie one bishop g4
it gets weird
so it still takes work i mean black has
a
pawn and a rook
and a knight for the queen
play rook here
oh no my bishop sure
if takes i would take and then mate um
[Music]
what to do with the bishop maybe bishop
c7
will just be weird bishop actually sits
kind of happily here
it's hard to remove it restricts this
knight
and covers the d8 square
i might be threatening to take and take
that's a weird position to internalize
what's going on
i should probably save the bishop
oh no my love is for you smile
everyone smile oh yeah everyone smile
smiles in the chat okay now if i take
the rook
oh it's so confusing i think i can get
away with this
bishop hear knight here and then takes
and then takes
and then takes and then takes but then
takes
33 event which baby i
may have messed this up
oh what did i do i have this move
it's a funny move
wow so after takes takes that this rook
is trapped by my bishops
and the light would still be hanging too
i have to watch out for my king like
bishop h3 and light here could come out
of nowhere
but the queen covers f3 for now
wow okay so this pawn is uh
looks like free food i have this funny
move too
what's what's this position bishop here
for the lols i should take a pawn first
i could take this thing too no let's
play this making a cube of some sort
it's so confusing
okay now i think i take
i have to take as my knight's hanging
and my rooks hanging
okay now there's an interesting trick
provoking rookie and the queen here
hitting this and this
so black now has two rooks for a queen
but i have a strong bishop
and muscles okay let's take a pawn
and night's restricted pawn is passed
i just want to win another i have this
move too
[Music]
yeah the knight and bishop controls so
many squares along with a queen
not quite threatening mate seems close
so let's do this and dig a pawn
light can't be taken
[Music]
down my time
queen is safe there
king will hide on g2
i like my chances i really like my
chances
okay okay that was a weird game
a lot of weird games so far
so the goal for this game was to take
all of my opponent's pieces
i almost succeeded but there were a few
survivors
okay so that was another game
i really just didn't know what was going
on
especially this position there is so
much
confusion all over the place
um stockfish the stockfish just says i'm
better
so i was worse oh i was worse here
also is e4 a good move
maybe objectively not good because
complicated reasons ah knight takes e4
so if the pawn we're hearing bishop or
here there's a line where you take and
play bishop d6
but that just doesn't exist here
of course it's hard to like as black if
you haven't seen this before it's hard
to
kind of differentiate and pawn takes
looks so much more natural
[Music]
wait knight c4
wow knight g4
oh naiji forgiving a square for the
queen
but then i've never seen this line
bishop c1
leaving the knight hanging but
threatening the the long diagonal shish
kebab
and then takes here block counter
attacks
and then calmly rook e1
wow some insane lines here
it's a type of variation like i should
probably study more of
but um like whoever knows the lines
better will probably come out ahead
but then still anything can happen
and then just to explain
yeah to explain this moment uh when i
played rook t3
oh actually if if knight takes bishop i
don't have to take immediately
it's just made in one yeah
i was hoping for the the oh no my bishop
anyway we're moving on 53rd place
undefeated so far getting some raining
i still have starbucks have a
a london fog peppermint london fog today
happy three months let's go rosen
let's go thank you like jj
okay maybe i'll repeat stafford or not
hope you have a good day d oh thanks you
too
hicks hexacoo
i think i haven't looked at this so
closely recently
but pretty sure this is a line
i really just uh
i try and know basic ideas from here oh
c5 is
let's just play c5
there's another line i should probably
investigate a bit
more closely more people play queen f3
these days rather than
knight f3 probably thanks to gotham
chess
okay now things are getting really weird
a lot of things are hanging if i take
what is this
i have to take some time here because
it's weird
so it takes takes check here queen e4
king f2
[Music]
i could just take the bishop
i really want to take the knight let's
take the bishop
i didn't see how other line could work
um okay with the bishop trade
i'll develop and attack the pawn
oh actually if knight d2 i win the pawn
so knight g4
[Music]
queen f5 or knight g5 queen f5
a confusing position for subbing
dr unken de groot
let's play this move
oh i didn't see that i could take the
rook and
oh no my queen
it's actually kind of interesting
otherwise i lose i can play this move
too
oh there's a cool line look at this
knight takes f7 castling
of protecting the king like avoiding 96
check
and skewering stuff and it might even be
better for me
it's still complicated knight d6
but then but then check here and then
takes
yeah i think it's winning there's no
queen f3
no queen b3
so here over here i take
oh there's that move i got too excited
game goes on maybe i play e3
king takes and then here
that's so weird
wait this might not be good for me
yeah i'm in trouble i was so proud of my
[Music]
move
i need a miracle to not lose this
i don't want to trade
good move i should have traded
i'm getting squeezed ooh free rook i'm
still losing though
it's so sad maybe i can hope for the
blunder
no my dignity
no wow
white one connect three on the on my
seventh rank
that's so sad
uh if i'm gonna lose i mean it's it's a
stylish way to
to go down
man i thought i was being stylish with
casting in this position
yeah i guess i i just underestimated
i was blind to queenie too actually
so in hindsight knight c6 should
probably be played
here
and then it's still a game
wow this computer graph
oh so the opening was fine
i'm checking masters database
oh bishop e7 is most played but this is
still
very playable okay this is a main line
yeah i was calculating uh takes takes
check
here here and from a distance it looks
interesting because the kings hear my
pawns here
but i just don't have a follow-up and
this is coming and my king's stuck
so okay let's move on
i i lost places
yeah it's the first uh
first loss of the tournament not so nice
but
moving on playing herna
even though chad is saying nice
completely for this game
okay we're gonna have a modern
a fun line to play against modern nice
oh thanks for being nice chat
let's castle go for rook t1
yeah i think you kenny lhasa
oh jeff jeffrey with the nice bits
it's a nice position put the bishop in
the knights are weird
i do have to watch the pawn
[Music]
how do i defend the pawn
because maybe i just don't
i don't have a move to defend the pawn
huh i'll just pretend that
black can't take it even though he can
okay so i'm down upon on the plus side
the knight is still a bit weird
i have the darks for bishop black has
weak dark squares
not super simple
in terms of how to attack
play knight g5
so we're going to trade queens we could
trade everything we trade knights then
i should win the e pawn
and the hope is to have a slightly
better position
just going into the endgame
the problem
put the rook in first actually
if i took too soon there's rook here in
here
yeah now we're gonna get uh i guess a
ninth versus bishop ending
and i have to try and prove why a bishop
is better than the knight
and black could check but this is more
likely
i'm not sure where the bishop should go
because knight hears coming and i'll
play this
yeah block's probably better here
the king's more active
yeah i'm getting all played
maybe i can try and make progress on the
king side like g4
i just want to make a pass pawn
okay so now i have this idea
okay making some progress
a really tricky position might be seven
objectively it should be equal now
[Music]
king is happier
if i need to win
down a little bit of time
um
it's so tricky to calculate so there's
pawn takes there's also night check
wait
it should be a draw
okay that's a draw and i was probably
worse at some points
um i don't think i'm winning after black
saxon night
am i yeah this is
a draw
actually the whole end game man the
graph is pretty flat actually but i was
worse i feel like i was worse when the
king got to gone in but maybe it was
okay
okay um we're moving on
yeah i'm not handling the predictions so
that's uh that's the job for mods
is there a refund
did the prediction not account for the
game being a draw
yeah sometimes you have to worry in the
right way like whether or not i'll win
thank you the og toxic z subbing for
three months
okay let's play i'll play in english
english is kind of my my backup opening
like a board of everything else
okay weird response from black
it's playable a little bit passive from
black
so i'm playing just uh trying to play a
very solid setup
considering c5 here
i don't know if it's good but it looks
interesting so it takes i play knight a4
so i'm temporarily down a pawn but the
the c pawns for black are quite weak
especially this pawn attacked four times
i probably could have taken it
immediately the whole point is when i
win this pawn
then the other pawns will be weak as
well
i might even i might just leave the pawn
here
attack something else
because how does black defend look here
then i probably take
there's no knight b6 knight b8
it's actually a really fun position
currently
[Music]
so i have knight b6 um
and too many nice looking possibilities
start by taking with knight
so i probably don't want to trade unless
there's a concrete line
so knight g3 just pressures e5 a bit
more
if knight takes before
at the very least i'll have bishop b6
winning material
not sure if i actually want to take but
i want to make black think
okay now i probably want to take
so this could lead to kind of a big
trade so takes takes i lose e4
um
uh it's it's hard for lack to calculate
two
and there's a lot of things to to worry
about
so by the time black figures everything
out there probably won't be enough time
on the clock
oh why starbucks i got lazy today
i gave in to my my craving opponent left
the game
maybe some connection issues like the
position is still playable
like takes takes this uh
it's not like easily winning for white
thank you morning wood 72 and klavny
and vox voxo tv
e-money yeah a lot of new subs
thanks to everyone who's subbing for the
first time
and resubbing degu solving for nine
months
did i miss my chance to claim victory
what's going on did i claim victory or
did black flag or maybe both things
happened at the same time
um as a strange finish to the game
so white's better here so takes takes
i think 94 it's just still very pleasant
for white i guess i win the pawn
okay let's move on
so trying to rebuild a streak
also thank you surfing usa
and maglor nolatari
a lot more people have been been playing
e4 today it seems like
okay we have another london
okay this line i i really enjoy
queen c1
i was preparing this for min lay uh he
likes to play queen c2 i think i can use
the same idea
of knight h5 hitting the bishop and then
prepare
this um sort of interesting
i guess in this case i play g6
yeah bishop e5 i have f6 e5
hmm
i probably want to keep my bishop here
even though the bishop's not so happy
here
uh it'll be useful later in the game e5
very typical
[Music]
yeah this is not the type of dream
london that
london players aspire to achieve
or if i can play knight g4
a long-term idea of queen h2 when the
knight's not here
ooh
can play h5 looks exotic
yeah it's a passive position for white
if either piece takes the pawn on g4
we'll uh we'll control f3 so then this
knight will be
very stuck and potentially this knight
too
um also if the pawn takes and takes i'll
have the plan of bishop f6
king g7 rook h8 some long-term meeting
ideas
hey thank you mr potato gifting to josh
the juice box
can i just keep improving
have to defend the pawn there's also
this interesting move
love your streams i love you too thank
you davey
i have this move i think i should start
with this move
i want to play actively rather than just
defensively
[Music]
f2 looks so delicious
oh i want to spend all my time here
i should really probably just take and
rook t8
but i want to do this and take and have
fun
maybe bishop here first so now if if
rook takes
i take on f2 and have tactics
that might be okay for white though oh
maybe if rook takes i take on e3
improvement okay here the knight has to
move
defend both pawns
oh it's um yeah white's winning a pawn
here
oops
yeah i have my time
oh i have this move maybe counter
winning upon
down a lot of time
okay this one's now weak
one whole year thanks for making the
past year a little better eric
oh my pleasure thank you tw welcome back
let's play this move
i don't know what to do
i'm in trouble too
so i'm defending from a distance might
be losing
[Music]
actually it's it's a bit weird probably
losing a pawn
[Music]
but time is the biggest factor here
look at this move g5 threatening this
and this i don't think i can stop both
threats
no that was a mouse slip okay now i'm
down the rook
oh no some bad pre-moving
that's a pretty that was a really dirty
finish
and was there meat
uh
h7 i always always had the f8 square for
the the king
in the event of queen h7 so it's just a
check
yeah i have i have clorox wipes to
wipe down everything after that game
i mean the the opening was actually
quite clean
i was happy with kind of the just a
positional setup
and then g5 was really nice
it was already getting messy but yeah
this was a pretty bad
pretty bad mouth slip
okay let's move on
let's move on
playing jake schneider
i'll go back to london
is this sponsored uh i don't think so
it is a dream to get sponsored by
starbucks
or any sort of tea company but
this stream specifically is not
sponsored
um yeah we'll play a bononi
oh welcome love common newton i missed
you too
yeah i took a few days off i've been
busy with just a lot of things but
um yeah the plan is to stream
obviously today and then tomorrow and
then i might be taking a small break
at some point soon
what kind of tea do i drink i have a ton
of
ton of different teas that i drink these
days
also that's a good move
i take those knight takes
yeah i already kind of bought this
opening i should have played a4 sooner
because i have this move
this is like a really good binoni for
black
like very often white should just
prevent b5
hey it's andrew chess welcome back
andrew tess
thanks for subbing for one year happy
anniversary
i think a few people have made the one
year mark
had tw earlier
andrew chess is one of the masterminds
behind
the the chat
was it the twitch tv
bot on the chest
which someone was asking about earlier
actually
oh okay my pawn is weak
have rook p1
yeah not my product opening so far
there's a weird line queen a2
oh it doesn't work
i was thinking knight c1 by my rookies
i don't know what i'm going to do after
this
maybe knight c3
takes and then rookie one
i might win the queen but i lose a lot
of material i could also play this move
this is this is not good because there's
takes takes and then
[Music]
bishop c3 knight d2
[Music]
i'm gonna have to bond cloud maybe
yeah i'm getting attacked from too many
directions
i'm staying alive though
i have this move it doesn't quite work
queen d4
i have this move so hitting the queen
these are bobby fischer pawns
whoa it's zen fortitude gifting five
subs
thank you zen fortitude appreciate that
i have to maintain some zen here
yeah it's hard to play rook a1 when the
bishop's here
some ideas to play e5 sack upon and then
rook a1
but really the position is not so bad
given
just a few moves ago
it still may be pretty bad let's attack
a knight
i just want to trap the queen
okay
losing a lot of pawns in the process
let's go i'm trying
black still has all eight pawns
i've lost half of my pawns
can i win this game without taking a
single pawn
what are blacks pawns what's this okay i
have to take a pawn
no
let's go okay what's that
blackhead what's the material imbalance
so in this position
i had a rook for six pawns
but the pawns ended up falling
black still had all eight pawns in this
position that was a funny game
okay back to tournament i gained one
rating point for that
top 50. let's go playing
oh it's maybe the highest rated opponent
so far
okay double berserking no time to waste
okay so we have one of these um i'm
playing in the style of casa corley
let's play this move
so my knight wants to come here
and we're getting something yeah very
positional
one plan is rook a2
b2 expected
okay
i think the king is safer here
some weird move queen b3
funny move i just want to trade queens
and then activate the the rooks on the
second rank
the problem is after takes takes rookie
2 is hard to stop
wow
i guess i could take
so maybe this or this
ah that's a good move
so the rook's now pinned and have ideas
of this
am i winning oh there's queen f3 this
might be a draw
i want to play for a win
i'm not seeing it okay it's gonna be a
draw
unless white tries to fog me
wow it's gonna try and flag me
i'm gonna win this
let's go okay
yeah white was trying to flag me i mean
there was some psychology there like i
i was taking more time i tried to get
myself low enough on time to make it
seem as if white could go for the flag
but it was a close call let's go
um yeah that should have been a draw
with this perpetual
okay but it was kind of a calculated
risk from from white i
maybe would have done the same thing
okay six minutes left let's finish
strong
thank you mr potato and gangrene all the
bits
yeah i think this youtube this uh arena
is youtube worthy
if i do post this on youtube
um people watching in the future on
youtube let me know if you've made it so
far
let me know your favorite game so far
from this tournament
uh feel free to post timestamps of your
favorite moments too
okay let's berserk and let's play d4
okay we have a pierce
going for more positional line early
queen trade
i should have a clear idea of what i'm
doing i'm just trying to put my pieces
on
happy squares try and be solid attack a
pawn
ooh probably don't want to lose exchange
idea maybe g4
have this move okay so i'm trying to
attack
like middle game attack without queens
on the board
okay alpha zero style
so now we can trade i win the pawn back
i probably want to keep pushing
threatening this maybe
is this mate a soon to be mate
yeah i made in two okay that was nice
oh one more maybe time for one more game
22nd place
what's that taylor swift song feeling 22
so three minutes left i'll probably
finish by berserking because why not
opponen's not berserking back so this is
some risk
oh did i play this person before
wait what is this move never seen that
move ever
in the history of chess of this move
i'm accepting whatever weird gambit this
is
it just takes again
i have to be careful though it's just
castle i want to play d5 eventually
oh am i losing a piece
also my time is not good
wow hi
this move i think this saves me actually
because i hit the knights
i still might be worse the problem is
takes takes takes
and then bishop d3 coming
bishop seven i guess
not down a lot of time
so i'm up upon the position
it's really difficult
yeah this is not gonna be pretty
so i'm trying to sack a pawn back just
to stay alive maybe you two can offer
each other draws lol
don't hurt me
oh there's rook takes that that would be
about really bad pretty move
i think rook takes was stronger there
actually
i'm still in big trouble yeah good move
i had to defend queen f7
this pawn's weak but okay there's
pressure between the bishops
oh wow what a move this move
so i couldn't take the bishop because oh
maybe i could have i don't know
knight six i have this move
barely staying alive
i just want to get a rook to f8 and made
along that file
[Music]
this pawn is giving me anxiety
please play this please
i just want to trade queens now
commission accomplished
the time is still not good i'll put the
rook on d5
kick the knight
ah i got forked oh i didn't get for it
no
no
i got mated oh what game
oh irene's back welcome back irene you
missed most of the tournaments
it was a good position here and then
yeah this was a timely move i mean white
could take here and then it's winning
but white
confused me more with g5 and it's still
probably winning for like cause the
pawns are
or is it i don't know it was still
tricky
but my time was so bad yeah white's
doing well okay
i'll still go on youtube that's a fun
tournament that was a weird game too
look at the graph it's like a nice sort
of pit
yeah white was
i mean i'm sure there were some
[Music]
some wind somewhere
it was plus five oh yeah so in this
position
i pre-moved this initially and then i
realized rook takes e6
and then i can't really take because
this is mating somehow
i guess white would still have to find
some
some knight e5 or knight g5
anyway for you two people
uh again time stamp your favorite moment
in the comments
and follow on twitch
also twitch chat says hi say hi back to
the twitch chat
do i like cheese depends on the type of
cheese
oh emo only chat ooh emote
only chat there we go okay
people are limited to the high youtube
emotes
and any other emote basically there we
go
okay also hello to yoshimitu
oh irene is testing yeah irene is exempt
from emotes
the power of being a vip
irene if you want to say anything to the
world this is your time and time to
shine
that was a fun tournament though it was
um
i mean i felt like i was in decent form
some games
didn't manage my time so well but had a
lot of a lot of fun moments